pendant tout le week-end les néophytes
de l'internet peuvent apprendre
gratuitement à surfer sur le web c'est
la quatrième édition de la fête de
l'internet avec des manifestations un
peu partout en france pour sensibiliser
un public encore parfois réticents
seulement 8 millions de français se
connectent régulièrement
reportage dans un cyber café parisien et
elle a cité des sciences de la villette
sophie rolland luc hedrich je voulais
vous faire une animation sur le
fonctionnement d'internet expliqué à des
enfants comment fonctionne cette immense
toile d'araignée pas simple c'est le
défi dan elle anime un atelier du net à
la cité des sciences à paris modem
routeur difficile d'éviter les mots
techniques pour se faire comprendre
enfin les ventes alors si je regarde ma
carte là tous les câbles qui sont
représentés ici représente le réseau
téléphonique et danseurs réseau
téléphonique
ce sont les ondes électriques circulent
ça va difficile à suivre les enfants ont
retenu l'essentiel même que sur internet
en trouver c'est des chevaux
vous pouvez parler à des gens après la
théorie la pratique notamment dans les
cybercafés pour beaucoup la fête du net
c'est l'occasion d'apprendre à surfer
sur la toile
c'est le cas de yannick et cyril ils
n'ont jamais utilisé internet de leur
vie premier réflexe trouver les sites
sur les voitures et les voyages premier
clic de souris plutôt ici ça s'est
plutôt bien passé donc là on a un petit
souci on sait pas pourquoi
les vrais internautes sont également au
rendez vous car aujourd'hui c'est
gratuit certains en ont même profité
pour enregistrer un message devant une
caméra message diffusé ensuite sur le
net
eh ben ça lui les branchés neuroniques
c'est la fête de l'internet
on y est tous ces technologies qu on ne
s'arrêtera pas mais pour l'instant les
branchés neuroniques ne sont que 8
millions en france soit 20 % des foyers
c'est beaucoup moins que nos voisins
européens aux pays bas 48 % des foyers
sont connectés